>> ABSOLUTELY WILD STORY OUT OF
WASHINGTON, THE FBI CHARGING TWO
MEN, POSING AS HOMELAND SECURITY
AGENTS, TARGETING FOUR SECRET
SERVICE AGENTS, INCLUDING ONE
WHO FOLLOW JILL BIDEN.
THEY ARE ACCUSED OF LAVISHING --
THE FOUR AGENTS BEING PLACED ON
PAID LEAVE.
YOU WERE SAYING HOW IS IT
POSSIBLE THIS HAPPENED.
>> Dana: GOOD NEWS, THEY WERE
CAUGHT, BAD NEW SYSTEM HOW LONG
IT COST TO DO THAT.
WHEN YOU WENT INTO THEIR
APARTMENT, READ WHAT THEY HAD.
AMMUNITION, SPOTTING DEVICES,
THEY WERE PLOTTING AND PLANNING
SOMETHING.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHAT THEY
WERE UP TO AND I'M SURE WE
PROBABLY WILL AND THANK YOU TO
THE INVESTIGATORS WHO FIGURED IT
OUT.  THE SECRET SERVICE
INTELLIGENCE EFFORTS HERE.
YOU COULD NOT GET INTO THE
CAPITOL FOR YEARS WITHOUT SIX
FORMS OF ID, HOW DID THEY
INFILTRATE AND TO GET SOMEBODY
THEY HAD GIVEN A FREE APARTMENT
WAS ON THE FIRST LADY'S DETAIL,
THAT IS DISGUSTING AND I BET JOE
BIDEN AND THE BIDENS THEMSELVES
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES MUST BE FURIOUS RIGHT
NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON SINCE
2020, THE FAUX AGENTS HAVE BEEN
WORKING AND HAD A NUMBER OF
MEETINGS WITH GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTORS AND WORKERS, THAT
OPENS A WHOLE CAN OF WORMS ABOUT
WHAT PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE TOLD
THEM.
>> I AM NOT INTERESTED IN THE
STORY, THE ANN APPLEBAUM STORY.
>> FAKE AGENTS PROTECTING A FAKE
DOCTOR, I'M KIDDING, SHE IS A
REAL DOCTOR.
SHE HAS A LOT OF PATIENCE WITH
JOE.
>> YOU ARE HOT TONIGHT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WORST THAN WATERGATE, THIS IS
WORSE THAN THE INSURRECTION,
THINK HOW MANY INSTITUTIONS ARE
COMPROMISED, THE PPUNIS
ARTLYP
FRAUD, JOURNALISM FRAUD, INTEL
AND BLACK LIVES MATTER FRAUD,
JUSTICES, THANK GOD OUR ELECTION
SYSTEM IS IMPEFR PERVIOUS.
>> JESSE, WHAT DO YOU FIND?
>> I CAN'T FOLLOW THAT, OH, BOY,
MAJOR -- SEE WHAT HAPPENED, I
HAD A BAG OF CHIPS DURING THE
BREAK.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHO TOLD YOU
TO HAVE A BAG OF CHIPS?
>> YOU DID.
>> OKAY,
>> Judge Jeanine: HIM OR ME?
>> PLAY CLEANUP.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT CONCERNS
ME, THESE GUYS HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY, THEY HAD A LOT OF ACCESS
TO PEOPLE THEY NEVER SHOULD HAVE
HAD ACCESS TO, THE FIRST LADY,
SECURITY DETAIL TO HER BODY
GUARD, IN PARTICULAR, TALKING
ABOUT SWAT VESTS, LARGE
COMPUTERS, HIGH-POWERED
TELESCOPES, INTERNAL
SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS, ACCESS TO
EXPENSIVE APARTMENTS IN
EXPENSIVE BUILDINGS, THERE IS
SOMEONE BEHIND THIS AND I'M
CONCERNED NOT ONLY FOR JOE BIDEN
AND ANYONE WITHIN THAT SPHERE,
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SECRET
SERVICE, BEEN HEARING TOO MUCH
ABOUT THEM IN THE LAST 10 YEARS
WITH ALL THE BREACHES AND THAT
IS ALL I HAVE TO SAY, THEY SAID
I DIDN'T HAVE TIME.
>> IN NORMAL PRESIDENCY, THIS
WOULD BE COVERED FOR TWO WEEKS
AND WOULD BE CONSIDERED A MAJOR
NATIONAL SECURITY BREACH.
ON THE HIGHEST LEVEL, THE SECRET
SERVICE WAS COMPROMISED BY
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE FROM
POSSIBLE IRANIAN INTELLIGENCE OR
PAKISTANI INTELLIGENCE, THIS
PRESIDENCY WITH JOE, THE BORDER
CRISIS, CRIME CRISIS, UKRAINE,
HUNTER, AS WE'VE COVERED, THIS
IS JUST ANOTHER SMALL BALL
SCANDAL, THIS IS MORE SERIOUS
THAN A LOT OF THINGS.
>> Dana: NOT JOE BIDEN'S FAULT.
>> IT IS CULTURE OF